hello everyone welcome back to the
channel for a south by southwest 2022
interview with the team behind i love my
dad james patton welcome to the channel
huge congratulations on your movie
thanks
thank you so much barry
all right so with a festival premiere
some of our viewers might not know what
your film is about just yet so james i'm
going to give this duty to you can you
tell everybody what i love my dad is
about yeah for sure so i love my dad is
about a divorced dad played by patton
who is cut out of his son's life his
son's going through a tough time
patton's character is worried about his
son and no matter what he does he can't
find a way to connect with them
so he creates a social media profile of
this girl and sends a friend request to
his son
and his son ends up falling in love with
this girl
uh patton was just trying to make sure
his son's okay but he then has to keep
up this thing with his son because his
son gets more and more invested as time
goes on
job well done but you left out a key
detail there
this is kind of based on a true story i
guess the key detail is that it's it's
based on something that happened to me
when i was when i was about 20 or so
uh which i which i'll get into now
basically uh my dad and i got into a big
fight
uh and i i blocked him online
and i was going through a tough time he
was worried about me uh i got home one
day this
really pretty girl had sent me a friend
request
on uh on facebook and i was really
excited
and uh
this story uh was born
it ended up being my dad
hey all right so patton i got some
questions about your involvement here
now first
this isn't a directorial debut for james
but he's still a newer voice behind the
lens so what was it about him and this
story that made you think yup this right
here is a project and a filmmaker i need
to commit myself to right now
well the script was fantastic and and it
really went where
um this story would go there wasn't any
shying away from
uh
any of the
cringy elements but also the hilarious
elements a lot of which were hand in
hand and
um i'm a big film buff and i like
working with
newer
voices writers directors and um
especially when i read a script this
ballsy it had that feeling of i just
want to see if we pull this off
you know like like the fact that this
kind of
chap there are there are very specific
challenges set up in the script i wanted
to see if we could pull those off you're
also involved as a producer here and
correct me if i'm wrong on this but i
believe it marks your first full
producing credit on a feature film
so yes this is the first full yeah full
uh feature film producer can mean a
million in one thing so what inspired
you to take on that role with this film
and then also what does producing mean
to you in general what are some of your
favorite elements of that role on a film
set i think the two best
most important elements producing
are keeping
um meddling away from the auteur or the
the mind or voice of the film um and
then also being able to suggest
who you think are the best people
um
you know based on your knowledge for
other roles or in other departments to
to kind of land the vision that the
filmmaker has i mean that's what all the
best producers um have always done
people like paulie platt um and people
like that so you know that's i was
trying to
keep myself within that realm and and
that mindset you know putting it
together i i feel like patent early on
helped me so much just like figure out
who is going to be the right who are
going to be the right
other people to to join us in the cast
and it was it was a pretty late in the
game decision for me to play the role of
franklin yeah and that was the decision
that patton helped me make because i was
we i went over his house and we we
screen tested me
playing the royal franklin because we
were like is this going to like is this
going to work
right yeah do we both feel comfortable
diving into this because it you know it
presents uh uh you know
a lot of opportunity but also a lot of
challenges and so i i feel like patton
really helped me navigate some of those
trickier decisions
uh and then throughout production i mean
patton was the first
like when we when patton came on board
that's when the project really came to
life and he had i
you know i've been a fan of patton since
i was a lot younger i remember seeing
him in big fan a long time ago and and
um
and he he has an ability to to tackle
really delicate subject matter with a
lot of heart and levity and and i think
that's what this story needed and so
throughout production i would sometimes
come to him be like how do you think we
can thread this needle tonally and he
would always
be uh super helpful in in helping me
execute in those ways
i have so many questions about the tone
of this movie and how you guys pulled it
off but first i want to go back to what
you just brought up about the casting i
have so many questions about this now
but i guess pat and i'll throw it to you
first what was it about your earliest
meetings with james that signaled to you
that this movie would be better off if
the director and the person who went
through this experience was also
starring in the lead role
well uh that was sort of the you sort of
answered your own question he has been
through this experience he knows the
damage that was done and he knew and he
also remembers probably
the giddiness and the euphoria of when
he was under the spell of the the con
more or less but also i i just thought
that it would make a little more sense
if um
the the part of the sun was a little bit
older i know that we were looking at
some much younger actors but there's
that instinct of if a kid is 17 or 18
going through some some stuff you just
go well it's a phase he'll get through
it but once they're in their 20s then
there is a real danger of this is how
they will be for the rest of their lives
and it i think any parent watching this
will will um you know understand oh
you've got to step in so they really i
wanted that element to be there and in
the early reads and the early you know
test screenings james just really
got into that fragility and got into
that oh this could be
this could decide the rest of this
person's life
made it way more you know dire so now
james for you what was it like maybe
writing the script with someone else in
mind and then you filling the role did
that part of the process wind up making
the character that we see on screen even
more true to your own experience yeah
you know i i think i wrote it
for myself to play i think i had that in
mind but then when it came to actually
executing i was like there's no way
people are gonna let me do this like
it's my first bigger film
they're not like this is a crazy ask to
be like i want to direct this and play
the lead it's like
no you can't do that like get out of
here uh but i but like i had
like pat was really the first person to
be like dude let's let's do this like
you can do this
and and when he got on board with that
idea then everybody else did too
um and and yeah i think
for me it was i i don't know it it added
like this this level of like
meta excitement to the whole movie where
it's like i i wanted to i wanted it to
be as as hyper personal as it possibly
could be to the point where it almost
felt like
too personal like i wanted to almost
have
too much skin in the game because it
adds this level of like
of extra cringe i think like that
you know
what what would you so i've seen the
whole movie a lot of people watching
this during south by southwest will not
have seen the film so i kind of know my
interpretation on this but what would
you say to someone who kind of reads a
little bit about your movie and
basically says like that's ridiculous
that's terrible how can a father do that
to a son what would you tell them to be
more open-minded and i guess kind of
maybe explain some of the additional
layers that they're going to see and i
love my dad yeah i think patna and i
talked a lot about this early on that
that that's part of the fun of the
premise how dangerous it can be and how
delicate we need to approach this
because it could so easily go into this
dark
kind of uh potentially gross territory
but chuck is never coming from a place
of like wanting to be romantically
involved in the sun right really trying
to help his son like he love he is such
he loves his son and he wants his son to
be okay so he's this is and we show
through the movie like this is really
his last
this is his last hope at making sure his
son is okay and and i think part of the
fun of it for us was to shu was to get
the audience complicit and on board with
such a ludicrous
action you know like
part of me wanted to understand in
writing it like
what would ever bring my dad to do this
and make it make it okay like why would
he ever think it was okay and so i
really wanted to take the audience on
that journey of like well here's how you
get to a place of thinking this is okay
and then being
trapped by this action you've taken so
that you have to go further and further
with it
but but never having it be from a place
where but oh but but having the audience
always be understanding of why the
father is doing this so for you now
patton is there a core quality in chuck
that was i guess really helpful in that
respect something that no matter what he
did over the course of the film it
always made it certain that all of his
actions were coming from a place of love
yeah he wants to be good
to the best of his ability and the key
phrase there is to the best of his
ability which is not that good in a
weird way it reminds me of the character
uh in this is going to sound very
pretentious in the film amadeus salieri
loves music he just has no talent for it
that chuck
loves his son but he has no parenting
skills and i think that that is a you
can have both of those you can totally
love your kids but be the worst person
to be raising them so um that that is
made very very clear early on that
there's no malice in this there's no
trying to he's not trying to get one
over on his son or get back at the world
he is doing a selfless act in the
absolute worst way he could go about
doing it
my heart this is this is such an extreme
scenario my dad has never catfished me
in my life but it's like applying this
idea to certain things that make so much
sense to me but he views in a different
way or doesn't fully understand i don't
know it's like thoughts like that make
me appreciate big extreme movies like
this because it helps me process truths
that i either couldn't or just wasn't
aware of before yes it it really ends up
going into some very interesting
places and and it never it never judges
any of the characters not only is it not
judge chuck it doesn't
judge the son the ex-wife the i mean
everyone is everyone here is trying to
do
their absolute best
and it's the trying that that's where
the love is coming from not necessarily
the success of the effort
of all the scenes in the movie maybe
without getting too far into spoiler
territory here was there anyone that was
the most difficult when it came to
balancing the comedic tone with
respecting the severity of the situation
mean it's a i feel like pat and you and
i are gonna be thinking the same one
yeah yeah can we get into it or do we i
don't wanna i don't wanna reveal it let
me put it this way let me i'm gonna put
this very delicately there is a scene
that is
and i'm not saying this is a brag
it is the height of hilarity and cringe
where
it is
the it is the
last act it is the last loving act of a
desperate man that absolutely should not
be being committed
and and i will and people watching the
movie i i can the way you're looking
down for you know the scene we're
talking about you know exactly the scene
we're talking about oh my god you're
crawling out of your skin watching it
but
but you there's a there's a reason that
he's doing it
oh god
i'm fairly certain i know what you're
talking about like yeah you know
all of those things um
all right let's make james blush a
little here so pat can you tell us about
james's approach to directing his actors
what is something that you really
appreciated about his approach to that
part of the job that you're excited for
other actors out there to get to
experience on his future films
well he's definitely you know that
you're in the hands of someone who is
thinking about the film all the time
he's not showing up on the same day that
you're showing up and being if you're if
you're showing up confused he's not
confused he has thought through these
scenes and he is open to talking to you
about them and if you get lost
he's willing to listen and and you know
go oh i can see what's going on there he
is thought through every aspect of this
world of these characters so you at
least know that you're in good hands if
you are
making some attempts or making some
choices that don't quite land you feel
safe doing that because you got a guy
there who's been thinking about it the
whole time
i always love that quality
all right james there's one particular
role i wanted to ask you about directing
and it's it's claudia's performance
because that seems like one of the most
exciting characters to play when they're
involved in the text message scenes
because it feels like it's part some of
her interpretation it's part what
franklin wants her to be it's what
chuck is making her out to be so what
was it like tackling that role with her
and what are some of the earlier notes
you gave her yeah i mean it's such a
complicated and fun character to play
because
she has to play the real becca in the
diner and then throughout the film she's
appearing as frank as as what franklin
is imagining
the texts that his dad is sending him
would sound like if they were embodied
in this girl he thinks is sending him
the messages and so
i think in terms of direct and claudia
we wanted to we wanted to she and i
wanted you know the three of us really
we had rehearsals together we were
trying to craft like okay
here's what the real becca and the diner
feels like and then this is what
this this person appearing to franklin
should feel like and it's sometimes we
we felt like it it should feel
very much like she
is chuck like she has this secret like
she knows
that she's actually chuck and then at
other points we felt like it should
really just be that she's a she's
exactly what franklin is imagining her
to be in those moments
and and you know she claudia's
pretty incredible in the film i think i
mean she she went
very deeply into the role
as as i think everyone in the cast did
um you know i think
i think patton set the tone on set of
like
how real
it needed to feel like he brought
such authenticity to everything he did
and was so prepared every day so that
and and through all the conversations we
had and everything he set the bar very
high so when claudia came on board she
wanted to
jump in as deeply she ended up working
some shifts at the diner that's right
and that her character did and so she
she
she was she went above and beyond to to
make sure that
this thing felt real and
uh i'm excited for people to see her
performance in the film yeah and she
created
she created such a real and alive
character that some of the most
startling moments in the movie is is
when the dream becca goes blank
when
when uh chuck is trying to think of the
next thing to say and she
is just sort of um uh
buffering if you will it's very strange
to see those moments it's really
startling because she's been so alive
in different ways up to that point and
she just she just nailed it amazing
amazing performance i thought i had had
enough of folks trying to bring
dming and text messaging to life on
screen and i've never i've never quite
seen it done this way it was very
exciting to me yeah
i yeah i think i mean i think that was a
part of it that we were we felt the same
way we're like we've seen it ha we've
just seen so much of it but it it it
really
so much of our life and our
relationships are just like
texts on a screen but it you know the
timing of the when they come through and
you know it feels like you're really in
direct conversation with this person but
so much of the experience you're having
is your own projection of what you're
thinking you're reading in so fully and
so so intensely to everything the
person's saying and so we it feels like
the person's right there
and it really is the pers exactly what
you
want the person to be uh so we wanted to
just physically show that yeah
you'll
you'll emphasize different words in the
text to suit whatever your needs are
even though the it's just a neutral
sentence but you can change that to make
it work for you which that's what so
much of the tragedy in this film so very
specific situation again but there are
some very universal concepts that have
ingrained themselves into my brain
all right yeah so as we wind down here
looking to the future so someone goes
and sees i love my dad james can you
tell us what some of your i mean this is
a big question but what some of your
goals are in the future and what kind of
films you're eager to direct from here
on out i i want the films to make to
feel
like you you hear the log line and you
you know that they're gonna they're
gonna be like exciting and
part like
uncomfortable but in a really fun way
um a part of this film that
kept me engaged the whole time was just
like how how personal it felt for me and
i i want
all of my films to feel that personal
whether or not they're based on literal
things that happen to me i want them to
feel like i have a lot of skin in the
game as the storyteller and that there's
a element of risk
uh to to whatever story i'm telling word
that if it's done wrong it could be done
really wrong
those are the movies that i'm attracted
to because it feels like you're watching
the filmmaker and the creatives involved
walking uh a tightrope and it it it
keeps you kind of like you kind of want
the person to fall but when they don't
it feels like they've pulled off a match
exhilarating
yeah i love you keep me coming back for
more with that description i love it
all right pat and i got two upcoming
questions for you or one potential
upcoming
modoc season two so i'll i'll be
you know fully honest with you i didn't
think modoc was gonna be for me at all
like i almost didn't even watch it
and then and then and then i did i feel
like i'm i'm first getting acclimated to
you know like r-rated adult animated
series and i've been covering like so
many wonderful things that yes are like
big and raunchy but have so much like
thematic resonance to them that i'm
surprised are sticking with me and i
feel like modoc was one of them
it's weird first off i can't say whether
we're doing season two yet that there's
i when you work for marvel you sign ndas
that are the size of phone books so i
have to be very circumspect but it's
where you bring up modoc because there
is some really
warped connective tissue between modoc
and i love my dad and that modoc is an
equally
catastrophically
horrible husband and father who is
trying and actually even worse than
chuck actually thinks he's nailing being
a dad there's a whereas chuck at least
has the has the decency to be desperate
and sweaty in what he's doing modoc has
this undercurrent of you're welcome i'm
really nailing this where he's he's just
destroying the lives of everyone around
him and as far as like already comic
stuff yeah there's been a nice
i don't know if you watched the new
season of peacemaker or harley quinn on
hbo max there's just been amazing
strides for also that show the boys
where
you know
if
if
if if if
someone is superhuman it means their
emotions and their faults are also going
to be superhuman and that's going to
lead to more insanity so you know
we really leaned into that when we did
modoc well no matter what happens i
appreciate season one and i am rooting
for season two all right thank you one
more question for you patton because
this is all i've heard about recently is
is about how you predicted uh boba
fett's survival so i'm gonna put you on
the spot here a little bit
give me another film franchise
prediction is there any other character
that like years and years down the line
we're gonna see crawl out of a sarlacc
pit or whatever applies to them
well if we're talking about like
underused characters or characters that
should be used more
i think that marvel is going to realize
they had an amazing franchise
in their laps for free
in their netflix shows with misty knight
and colleen wing those two actors um
they will someone in five years
hopefully sooner will realize do that a
low stakes gritty street level
superhero noir with those two characters
misty knight and connolly wing they're
sitting right there so i'm predicting
that someone at marvel will realize what
they've got and they will run with it
every time i want someone to manifest
something i'm coming straight to you
i'm i'm pulling all the energy i can
i'm summoning the multi-purpose i love
it all right i gotta let you guys go you
got a lot of uh south by southwest
celebrating to do huge congratulations
on i love my dad james i can't wait to
see more from you and patton for years
and years you keep delivering so keep it
up thanks